people spend a lot of time looking
forward to their next meal will be pizza
a burger a salad or a bus I mean could
you eat a bus a strange question it
seems but let's find out the point of
eating is to provide your body with
energy food enters through the mouth
where it's broken down into smaller
pieces by saliva and chewing it then
enters the belly where the movement of
the muscles around the stomach and
gastric juices break it down further
from the stomach the mixture of food
passes into the small intestine and
large intestine or useful nutrients and
water from your meal are absorbed the
remaining material is waste and becomes
a poop which exits through your butthole
enzymes are molecules in our body which
helps speed up the reactions and
chemically break down food they are
present throughout most of the digestive
process but are picky about what they
want to break down for example in your
saliva the enzyme amylase starts
breaking down carbohydrates to maltose a
type of sugar but in the small intestine
another enzyme called maltase converts
the maltose to glucose which is then
used for energy by the body however some
people lack the necessary enzymes to
break down specific foods consider the
case of lactose intolerance where the
body is unable to produce sufficient
levels of the enzyme lactase to break
down lactose found in foods like milk
yogurt and cheese as a result they can
have problems with digestion such as
abdominal bloating farting or nausea
when it comes to eating a bus we don't
have enzymes specifically designed to
chemically break down glass steel or
plastic but that hasn't stopped humans
from eating remarkable things
mashaallah Tito a French entertainer
known as mr. eat everything consumed
among other things a computer a pair of
skis six chandeliers and an airplane
this task took two years to finish to do
it he disassembled items and cut them
into small pieces which he ate with
regular meals he added mineral oil to
lubricate the passage of the small
pieces and lots of water to wash them
all down Lotito claimed to eat
approximately one kilogram of non-food
material daily while doing these stunts
from which he amazingly suffered no ill
effects to his health it turns out he
had an insatiable desire to eat things
like
rubber and metal a condition known as
Piko Piko differs from person to person
some people consume non-food items to
satisfy an appetite due to extreme
mineral deficiency whereas other cases
of pica are related to psychological
disorders mica can be quite dangerous as
severe complications may arise from
eating things our bodies weren't
designed to process so then how did
Michele Lotito do it it said that Lotito
had an abnormally thick stomach lining
which prevented structural damage as the
metal passed through his system in this
case he just got lucky that his pica
coincided with a well suited biological
abnormality
so could you eat a bus hypothetically
maybe with a rare thick stomach lining
and the bus chopped into tiny pieces
over many years it might be possible but
technically since you don't produce any
enzymes for it and you aren't absorbing
any nutrients you aren't actually eating
the bus just simply passing it through
and we don't exactly recommend trying to
find out if you can just don't special
thanks to audible for supporting this
episode to give you a free 30-day trial
at audible.com slash ASAP this week we
wanted to recommend the book what if by
randall munroe which does an amazing job
at answering hilarious and sometimes
absurd hypothetical questions it's
honestly a fantastic book you can get a
free 30-day trial at audible.com slash
ASAP and choose from their massive
selection we love them as they're great
when you're on the go and subscribe for
more weekly science videos